[Musica]
provate ad immaginare per un attimo di
vivere in una casa dalle pareti di vetro
in questa casa tutto quello che fate è
visibile a chiunque sia ai vostri vicini
ma soprattutto anche agli sconosciuti
seppure nessuno vorrebbe vivere in una
casa come questa le cose sui social sono
proprio così
sui social infatti tendiamo a
condividere i nostri momenti di
quotidianità con tutte le persone
intorno a noi condividiamo le foto delle
nostre vacanze oppure quella dei nostri
figli oppure quelli di momenti
importanti con la nostra famiglia oppure
con i nostri amici ma pensateci un
attimo il fatto di condividere tutte
queste informazioni non ci porta a
vivere in una casa di vetro
eppure tutto questo non ci saranno un
problema
d'altronde siamo noi stessi in maniera
volontaria a pubblicare tutte queste
informazioni
possiamo scegliere quale foto pubblicare
oppure se rimuovere un commento che non
ci piace più
inoltre possiamo scegliere con chi
condividere questi contenuti e chi
invece escludere qual è il problema
allora siamo noi in controllo delle
nostre informazioni
no no questa è solo un'illusione
i problemi infatti è che ogni azione che
facciamo sui social può avere delle
gravi conseguenze anche sulle nostre
vite lavorando da anni nel mondo della
cyber security sono quotidianamente a
contatto con i dati sensibili in questi
anni ho capito quindi il valore della
segretezza e della riservatezza delle
nostre informazioni ma soprattutto
volevo capito è che non è necessario
eliminare internet dalle nostre vite per
prenderci cura dei nostri dati tutto
quello che possiamo fare
però è un compromesso forse mai fatti
costruire una casa con i muri mattone
che tuteli la nostra privacy
ma come ogni casa anche con qualche
finestra che ci esponga al mondo esterno
questo compromesso però possiamo
compierlo solo se ci rendiamo conto di
quali sono
i rischi a cui andiamo incontro quando
condividiamo qualcosa sui social
ma quali sono questi rischi per
cominciare vi faccio una domanda che
magari può sembrare anche banale secondo
voi quanto il nostro profilo social può
compromettere un colloquio di lavoro
la risposta personalmente mi ha stupito
infatti secondo una recente ricerca
italiana ben il 44 per cento dei
selezionatori ammesso aver scartato un
candidato aver visualizzato il suo
profilo social le principali motivazioni
sono tre la prima è che questa persona
ha postato delle foto sconvenienti
la seconda sono delle informazioni non
coerenti con il curriculum e la terza
sono state dei contenuti discriminatori
ma non sono solo le persone che cercano
lavoro ad essere danneggiati dal proprio
profilo social
in italia infatti alcune persone hanno
perso il proprio posto proprio a causa
per dei post condivisi su facebook altre
aziende invece hanno visto a
danneggiarsi la propria credibilità e
immagine per dei posti sono stati
controversi e comunque molto opinabili
questi però sono solo alcuni dei rischi
a cui andiamo incontro a quando ci
dimentichiamo che i social sono delle
case di vetro c'è un problema che mi
preoccupa molto di più e questo riguarda
un discorso che non credo che venga
affrontato con la giusta consapevolezza
your ne sono reso conto in questi anni
perché alcuni dei miei amici convinzione
diventare genitori
il problema infatti riguardi danni che
facciamo i nostri figli quando
condividiamo online le loro informazioni
e le loro foto negli ultimi anni si sta
sviluppando un fenomeno chiamato sharing
questa è la tendenza dei genitori nel
condividere online tutto quello che
riguarda la vita dei propri figli dalle
prime parole ai primi passi fino alla
forza dei primi giorni di scuola alla
laurea e così via
secondo un'indagine americana quasi un
genitore su 3 pubblica ogni giorno una
foto dei propri figli sui social network
un altro studio inglese invece afferma
che i media
un ragazzo di 13 anni si trova condivisa
dai genitori circa 1.300 tra foto o
video anche se le statistiche non
arrivano dall'italia
penso che tutti voi possiate constatare
come questo sia un fenomeno molto
diffuso
siamo arrivati al punto che bambino
nasce veramente solo quando i genitori
pubblica nostra foto su facebook ma
anche qua verrebbe da chiedersi qual è
il problema
d'altronde non sono solo foto o dvd
innocenti che male possono fare i
problemi sono sostanzialmente due il
primo è che queste informazioni sono
pubbliche e quindi disponibili a
chiunque
sono disponibili anche alle persone che
vogliono utilizzarle per fare del male
oppure danneggiare il nostro figlio
pensate solo se un giorno fosse preso di
mira da un bullo questo bullo avrebbe
delle foto molto sensibili e personali
il nostro figlio per offenderlo
prenderlo in giro oppure schernirlo un
altro rischio molto preoccupante
ovviamente è quello della pedofilia
secondo l'indagine australiana quasi il
50 per cento dei contenuti che girano
sui forum legato a questo ambito è preso
proprio dai social network un alto
rischio molto concreto è quello del
furto di identità perché insieme alle
foto pubblichiamo ai tantissimi
informazioni sensibili del nostro figlio
è stimato che entro il 2030 quasi due
terzi dei furti d'identità riguarderanno
proprio le informazioni condivise dai
genitori sui figli bullismo pedofilia e
furto d'identità dobbiamo renderci conto
che ogni volta che pubblichiamo una foto
sui social network di nostro figlio non
stiamo apprendendo quella foto dentro il
soggiorno di casa nostra dove sono gli
ospiti che rientrano non possono vederla
ma la stiamo pubblicando sui muri
esterni dove tutte le persone che
passano non possono vederla
e questo il primo problema il secondo
problema invece è che queste
informazioni sono permanenti
da quando li condividiamo infatti non
possiamo sapere chi le ha scaricate per
poi ri condividerle in privato
se quindi un giorno decidessimo di
scaricare di cancellare una foto del
nostro profilo social non potremo mai
essere sicuri che questo non sia più
presente su internet
proprio per questo motivo le foto che
condividiamo dei nostri figli sono
permanenti proprio come dei tatuaggi e
se anche un giorno nostro figlio
decidesse di farsi un tatuaggio potrà
farlo scegliendo autonomamente cosa è
giusto fare e cosa no così come per i
tatuaggi quindi dobbiamo lasciare che i
nostri figli condividano autonomamente
cosa su internet le loro foto scegliendo
per loro cosa è giusto e cosa no senza
essere noi a violare la sua libertà
provate a metterli nei suoi panni per un
attimo come vi sentireste se da adulti
scopriste che una cosa così personale ma
anche sensibile con i vostri album
dell'infanzia fossero sui social in
maniera pubblica e permanente
proprio per questi motivi prima di
condividere una foto che ritrae i nostri
figli sui social è giusto porsi almeno
un paio di domande ho davvero bisogno di
pubblicare questa foto
può questa foto essere dannosa per mio
figlio nel presente ma anche nel futuro
se ancora siamo convinti che pubblicare
quella foto non comporti alcun rischio
per il nostro figlio allora ci sono
almeno un paio di accorgimenti che
possiamo prendere per creare un
compromesso con la sua privacy
in questa foto per esempio sono mostrati
solo dei dettagli del corpo del bambino
in questo modo non andiamo a raffigurare
e mostrare i particolari che lo vanno a
identificare facendo un compromesso con
la sua privacy
in quest'altra forte invece sono state
utilizzate delle mode per coprire i
volti dei più piccoli questa foto è
stata scattata durante una vigilia di
natale con la mia famiglia e queste sono
le persone che al mondo vi sono più a
cuore
proprio per questo motivo i volti dei
più piccoli sono stati coperti con
dell'emotion per creare anche in questo
caso un compromesso con la loro privacy
puoi smettere di compromettere il futuro
di tuo figlio solo se comincia ad
affrontare questo discorso con la giusta
consapevolezza puoi farlo già oggi e
sono sicuro che un giorno tuo figlio ti
ringrazierà per averlo fatto
devi renderti conto che sta vivendo i
social pensando che questi siano le
cause in cui vivi ogni giorno in mattoni
sicure ma non è così i social sono le
cause come quelle che vedete qua dietro
cioè casi di vetro dove la nostra
privacy è costantemente a rischio e dove
noi i nostri cari
siamo più vulnerabili
[Applauso]